hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany my
guest today is a man who has never been
a professional musician but is
nevertheless at the helm of one of the
greatest orchestras in the world the
orchestra in question is the Berlin
Philharmonic and the man I'm talking
about is right here with me now Martin
Hoffman thank you very much for joining
us here today on talking Germany it's
the pleasure pleasure of me too great
stuff now Martin Hoffman might not be a
musician by profession in fact he
started out as a lawyer before carving
out a career in commercial TV management
and for the past three years or so he's
been the general manager of the Berlin
Philharmonic Orchestra what's more he is
the person of this glorious institution
one that simply oozes tradition is
hoping will guide it into the future
you're not Inc I've got it right you
have said Martin Hoffman that the Berlin
Philharmonic Orchestra and I'm quoting
isn't just music yeah it's an attitude a
philosophy and a very special way of
life or of looking at life I think he
said yeah described that way of looking
at life that philosophy that attitude oh
I think the Berlin Philharmonic all
members of the Berlin Philharmonic see
musicians and so chief conductor as a
conductors are really living using and
it's for them it's part of their life
and it's part of their belief the music
can give some help or support your daily
life and it's it's for them it must to
hear music and to make music and to to
give something back to the society which
is absolutely and their understanding
necessary what's a wonderful description
giving help and support in everyday life
a major Symphony Orchestra I love it I
love it yeah fantastic life is like the
best thing we can do great stuff you of
course your role I mean not your role
where you're coming from you came from
commercial TV right in commercial TV
entertainment is a very big factor how
much of an of a factor for the orchestra
is entertainment
oh I would say that's not the most
important thing and we are doing
entertainment does a self understanding
of the orchestra is really to make the
best music to be in a very and our
target crew is not so but so white and
dent and big we are really making music
for a certain kind of people which are
really interested in this kind of music
and for this we want to provide them
with the best music and the best
Orchestra you can imagine and so
entertainment is not the right word what
we try to do is to open to open the
society or to open people for our music
to find that they find our music quite
interesting and this is what we are
doing and we are not doing it with
entertainment we are doing every concert
in the best way we can do but we are
using to get the younger audience or you
get a younger target group or two to get
the upcoming generation into the concert
hall we try to do everything but what
you might call entertainment we are
using all new platforms all new
distribution opportunities but it's not
in this TV understanding and ok if I
understand you correctly what you're
saying is that your target audience of
people who take their music seriously
and Germans certainly do take their
music seriously so my next question is
to what extent is the Berlin
Philharmonic Orchestra a German
orchestra quite interesting I let me if
you want to have the precise figures
it's quite easy to explain ok you're not
a start yeah we have 128 members
musicians and they are coming round
about now close to 30 nations so and
actually the majority majority of the
musicians is are still chairman's but
it's more miss half and half when I have
it
when I counted right it's more than 60
musicians still coming from Germany okay
I'm going to break it off there because
there's lots of things we need to talk
about their you know in a little bit and
the most important word in what you just
said was the word still because
something is happening there something
is changing okay you've had your first
impressions there from Martin off man
here is more after four years as general
manager of the Berlin Philharmonic
Orchestra Martin Hoffman says his task
is as complex as a Mahler symphony
the 54 year old from southwest Germany
has been interested in music since
childhood he played violin in the Youth
Orchestra and has always sought contact
to musicians cunha taqman shift this is
an Air Force contiguity he left the
Youth Orchestra behind to study law but
he maintained a subscription to the
Berlin Philharmonic
for 10 years he worked in the commercial
television sector eventually becoming
the managing director at the science
network in 2010 he returned to his old
love classical music an architect
Hansen's Phil emoni so doesn't a fast
Indiana Sharon included these
fascinating details this here is like a
ship's portal she's Olga with his wealth
of experience Hoffman is steering the
Philharmonic into the digital age one
example is the digital concert hall
where six cameras broadcast every
concert live via the internet it's
exclusive content for the more than
15,000 paying subscribers worldwide
Hoffman has also introduced public
screenings in cinemas making classical
music accessible to everyone his motto
is excellent not elitist and late night
concerts are accessible via a mobile app
Martin Hoffman can concentrate on
management and marketing and leaves the
artistic decisions up to the musicians
and their head conductor Simon Rattle
still he enjoys accompanying the
orchestra on its guest appearances
around the world it's a dream job in a
place that's bursting with musical
history this is the carry-on entrance my
entrance the funny thing is that carry
on had it installed to allow him the
shortest possible route to and from the
stage and sometimes while the audience
was still applauding he was already in
his car on his way home
today he's our guest on talking Germany
Martin Hoffman and you know what we were
just talking about it being a dream job
or not and he said how Martin Hoffman
said no it's not a dream job it's not a
dream job you know I didn't oh no it's
completely wrong it certainly it's a
dream but in every job you have
something to do it's not always not 12
hours a day dream job but 10 hours per
day sorry I was just pulling it like at
the end there you were talking about her
epiphone carry on and his little sort of
escape route ounces until ammonium to
what extent does does have the spirit
let's call it the spirit of herbert von
karajan still exercise an influence over
the building of the orchestra not first
of all not I think main influence he has
actually is the building's the other
it's it's still his kind of making music
it's very interesting that 30 round
about 30 musicians performed a plate
under have a thong kebaya young and one
of the most exciting things you view you
can have for most interesting
discussions is if you have if you talk
to these musicians everyone by everybody
has a personal impression the personal
experience and a certain and very
convinced opinion about habit from
kalyan and they told me that so in the
DNA of the orchestra is still something
from Hobart for kya he was so for so
many what is that something but they FA
because that's the quote in the report
which I think it's quite interesting and
I know it's very close to your heart
almost your sort of motto not elitism
but excellence yeah ok I mean herbert
von karajan for all his merits and I saw
him conduct and I and I I could sense
you know really a long way back in the
chamber a long way from the man himself
I could sense his charisma and the
Marvel of the music but elitism was also
a part of sort of his package was here
sizing so it
so he really had something like this and
he for example he established his
salzburg festival and it was definitely
a festival and not for everyone it was
for is a really upper class and but at
the same time he opened the music or he
distributed to his music to everybody
hmm for example ufc's triangle Berlin
Philharmonic Deutsche Grammophon and
halibut phone card on which was in a
certain period in 270 seventies it was
it was it was young I was young and by
my parents bought all these discs and it
was classical music what this triangle
Berlin Philharmonic and Hobart vakharia
but what they are still half and this is
a serious answer they have some
understanding of making music still
coming from this time and there are a
lot of changes but they can remember the
sound and they can remember how to make
music and how to listen to each other
and it's certain quality that it is
still it's not in the every
interpretation it's totally you now you
hear a beat often cycle completely
different or Brahms is totally from
other contactors completely different as
having fun carry anything but it's so
the way of making music of being
together of end as well to do the best
what they can do in every concert is
still time seeing what they have in mind
okay the new principal conductor he has
been the principal conductor for quite a
while we're actually now talking about
him leaving the orchestra is Sir Simon
Rattle he has changed the orchestra
around a little when you arrived at the
orchestra so Simon said of you Martin
Hoffman will help us to redefine the
role of the orchestra in the 20th
century come on it's too big that's what
he says yeah it was it was a major vote
of confidence in you as a person it's
the kind of thing he's got to say of
course but we can you for me define the
redefining what what do you aspire to
what but what we had in mind and what
does discussion is still ongoing
discussion and the orchestra what is
really something which is in our mind
and what we have to think is how we can
get younger audience how we can get
upcoming generation you know when we
both or when I was young it was part of
my education two-year classical music I
have to practice violin III had music in
school and I went with my parents to
operate some concepts and this is
actually not in the way I had it if you
can't compare it with in with our time
or in our times and so we and and the
whole institution try to figure out how
we can get or we can we can make our
music or can can create an interest it's
a strong interest and and in the best
way a passion for our music and this is
mr. you have to use even the easiest way
would be to get David Garrett who was
here a few no it's not this is exactly
right guy he's great is trained as a
great whining player but it's really and
you've got all in this so don't know
it's it's not the way we are doing it
there beside this david kerr it's an
excellent musician an excellent violin
player knee he crew up he was one of the
most talented wildest in the world
absolutely um what we trying to do is to
open to men the program as well you're
doing this modern music and we are we
are offering new formats such as late
night music last time you had late night
music we started with the idea and we
effect that's the first concert 500
people and so we decided free seating
and 10 euros one ticket and it was so so
we expected okay it starts at half-past
ten you will get three four five hundred
people and the third concept yet in the
row and in its form is late night
concert we had more than 1,500 people
and we had to close the doors because
people have seen the first as a
prime-time concerts eight o'clock
concert and three 1300 people who are
standing outside and knocking on the
door and so it was quite dangerous
situation as well this is a way we try
a one example how we try to make our our
music accessible we are doing in two
months time for the first time an
open-air concert just before in front of
the Fulani and we are working together
with all other cultural institutions
museums and libraries which are located
in this wonderful place and this is
other other chance to improve how often
do you go to the concerts at the fella
Moni you know normally only regular
basis we are doing in one season close
to 90 concert hmm in in a year hmm that
means 30 programs and one program i sees
or one concert i see every time or so
far most most of the time I'm seeing it
twice lucky man and do you have your own
seat absolutely really yeah where is it
it's very well located I have to chance
the front row second row three it quite
quick I think the parcels ourselves out
of the hall the best seats are in about
row 10 i would say in the middle that's
exactly where i am seated ok look out
for you next time ago boom boom you
don't want to be an elitist orchestra so
yeah you have cheap seats we have flow
price seats I would say and what's the
difference between cheap and low price
too yeah but but the quality yeah I'm
off the seed sis and this is a very good
invention sharoon mate it was the first
time in this hole this is concert hall
he built something like a democratic
concert hall and this means not even one
seat hmm is fara than 33 meters from the
stage there are different views
certainly and but it one of his really
thoughts and his strong believes yeah he
should create a democratic concert hall
and because of this i have problems if
you
saying cheap beats we would not want
enter by Zeus give our view as an idea
though of what are the cheapest seats
because I know this is important to you
what I watched it how much do they cost
we have from 10 to 17 euros cheaper
seats and very close to a ticket for
cinemas and we make this accessible or
we have eav are offering for every
concerts seats and tickets in this
category yeah and so the highest or the
the best best seats are sold the highest
category between 90 and 100 25 years
just tell me a little bit about the
building is it is the building is it is
it a good I mean it's clearly for the
audience it's an intimate place no
matter where you're sitting I absolutely
take your point that it's a very
democratic Allah torium is it a good
auditorium but we've heard the yoga the
acoustics are famously good but is it is
it a good place for the musicians to
play yeah absolutely yes they travel the
world when you compare it is very
interesting because they feel really is
a Berlin Philharmonic it's their home
higher and it is in their hearts and its
really it's their place to perform and
very interesting and one of the most are
most interesting discussions we have
when we decide where to 20 wherever you
want to go in which city want to we want
to go is how is Sakura sticks really and
the other is every of these certain
destinations yeah not really in our mind
because I acoustic is not so good and
few examples of Berlin Philharmonic it's
an exam is so um is copied so many times
internationally yeah so like the city of
the Opera House is often great is often
quoted yeah nobody's two holes old
architecture it'll get Centuri Hall in
Japan for example you know Kevin towers
in Leipzig it's the same same idea same
basic construction you have it in in
Disney Hall in Los Angeles it's really
it's coming from this genius
vention from Han stolen and vs ole could
you remember your first visit to the
fyke and literally remember when I was I
think I was 17 years old and I went to
the Berlin Philharmonic for the first
time to the phil hartmani yeah and i can
remember sort of ah because from outside
there are two different sort of it's
it's sort of like a split personality
from outside it's it's very metallic
yeah and quite brash yeah and on the
inside it's very very it's there's a lot
of wood and it feels extremely
comfortable but there's something
breathtaking about it now it's
absolutely set the same experience I
made if you're coming to see is a
building it's so you can't compare it
with any other architecture in the world
it's so unique and its certain style
it's and you know when it's your own
building and but interesting if you're
going to the four-year for example you
see or you can imagine that this
building is created in the early sore
let's say in the last century you have a
feeling you have a certain kind of
atmosphere certain kind of ah yeah you
can't then there is the diamond going to
halt yeah but there's the danger at some
stage that the building is going to
become a little bit of a museum item not
at all this i don't know this i wouldn't
say it's concerns only concerns so for
ye so far as I feel it maybe you have
another impression but when you go into
the hole you can't if you close your
eyes and you ask yourself which time
this building is created or made it you
can't really answer it true it's still
really actual and it could even be some
time in the future oh that's mornin okay
even the biggest and the best orchestras
need big names as soloists of one of the
undoubted superstars of contemporary
classical music is the Chinese pianist
lang Lang and last year the Berlin
Philharmonic Orchestra got together with
the maestro to record their first CD
together let's listen in just a wee
little bit too Bartok it's the the
Second Piano Concerto why not
you
we make little little Corrections like
someone restoring a painting what can we
make better what's important what's not
coming out Liang Liang and I would go
and listen and say oh my god that sounds
different than we thought which often
happens you think some things which
weren't coming out sound very
exaggerated and other things you don't
hear at all
yeah we care this is not good this we
get slow to both of us to sit in it yeah
and false well sure what he said that he
says forced or its faults but it was it
that was interesting to observe the two
of them they're together working so
closely together what would you say
would you say the Berlin Philharmonic
and ylang-ylang is a marriage made in
heaven or is it more problematic no not
at all its Liang Liang is one of our
wonderful soloist with performing on a
regular basis empties big star in the
classical world but it's so we are doing
regarding piano soloists we are doing it
with some great other musicians as well
Christian Zimmerman we affect it was a
wonderful concert if in point when we
are going actually with him ban ban to
the new festival so long long is one of
our most wonderfully well I've got a
quote from you one reviewer said of the
CD that were that was being recorded
there it said it all gives a whole new
meaning to the words flash bang wallop
yeah that sounds a little bit more like
entertainment than less a little bit
less like the state leisure repeat is
discussion concerning entertainment but
it's but but it's interesting that Thun
pianists in Berlin have a certain
audience and for example antosh if we
had room on a regular basis recital
since the Chamber Music Hall it's
unbelievable it's sold out in a second
and mauricio Pelini is coming or was two
weeks ago with us and it was saying no
to donor car and actually we have yet in
point man who is just or had loop who
was here last week and in Berlin you can
say some soloists have a certain
audience and they're coming every time
when they have the chance to hear these
musicians ok we mentioned the fact
already that because we saw Sir Simon
Rattle working there with Liang Liang
together is very interesting to see them
in their in their sort of leisure gear
yeah
and Sir Simon is leaving the orchestra
by 2018 right what does that mean for
the orchestra it's one of the most of
the most important decision is who is
the chief conductor and musical director
and so we have only we have had only a
few after this in the last 60 years and
um so it's a discussion and its decision
made as well I is orchestra yeah by
every musician has one vote 128 votes
128 years and who's your favorite well
what did what have you been earning
hearing what are the rumors absolutely
there are a lot of rumors and you can't
comment and but don't another former
guest he loves being mentioned without
telling you even one name as you can
imagine that I never would do so but
what I can't really see and what you can
regarding the history of the decisions
of the orchestra it was always a very
intelligent from time to time surprising
and a good decision for the institution
and I have a deep confidence and I trust
these 128 musicians that they've made it
again and it will be in the in the
course of the next year okay we look
forward to the outcome of that decision
baby myself yeah
youth makes music you used to be a
musician a junior musician yourself did
you ever take part in this I was just
very close to take part it's a
competition but one of the reasons I
didn't become professional musicians was
because I was not so talented you take
part of this competitions what did you
what did you most enjoy playing when you
were a youngster what kind of peace kind
of pieces huh at the end it was a cool i
arm all concert it was and beyond
Sebastian Bach I did wonderful pieces
and but it was work to do and it's
really hard to become or two to get the
knowledge to to play such an instrument
and I mean it's clear that this program
is is really pretty competitive two
winners from this program have former
winners or food you know youngsters
who've taken part in this program have
they actually made their way into the
fellow money indeed Indian I don't know
exactly the number but many of our
musicians Wow ah or at least say as a
one ah this competition but then it's a
first step and then yes I have to study
and to approve to improve their skills
that's interesting so I mean but it
shows that the program is actually very
very very strong it's really really not
really strong and on top of that the the
the BPO has its own music academy yes
was that's quite unusual i don't think
most most major orchestras don't you
know why what what's the function yeah
it was an invention as well from habit
on kaya and go okay how we are we can do
in our time so in difficult times how we
can make our the next musicians coming
or to get the right musicians for the
orchestra and this is a past studies
school or opportunity to improve the
skills on the instrument and one of the
ice i would say sir t exactly thirty
members
actually performing into orchestra has
made this trainee program or this post
graduate studies at Zurich enemy so it's
a pretty direct route into the already
directly know and then we have a
wonderful wonderful situation just half
year ago they were looking for as a
position of the first solo cellist and
it's really something in the music world
to become this position you and as
audition two paths and finally a member
of the Academy took over and won this
competition entry expected coming in
ahead of some other coming from this the
real favorite is the age of his career
and he get really very important and a
wonderful position said means this
Academy VF actually said you know 25
people who having the scholarship and
and they are coming from all over the
world mm-hmm that's interesting this is
Chris we've got to go back to that point
that we mentioned earlier that you said
that the majority of the musicians in
the orchestra are still Germans and that
seemed to indicate that from the new
intake there's probably a majority who
are not Germans has that got anything to
do with the fact it's often said that
the young German musicians these days
aren't hungry enough they're not
determined an ambitious it's not on this
level and it's if you have a look we
have 28 nations all together there's not
a maturity coming what you might have in
mind coming from Asia it's absolutely
not not our last best player bass
players coming from a kind I think you
correct it it's really we have members
from all nations in Europe and worldwide
and regarding the German musicians what
musicians told me members of the
orchestra what they are telling me is
that has a quality and it's a way how
can how they are able to play this
articulately technically and even on
this level musically they are really
really really outstanding performances
you can hear in this auditions and this
improved over the last last 20 years
okay and but it's absolutely the top
level we are looking for and we are
getting
have you ever thought about going to a
monastery seat going sort of seeking
refuge from the modern world in a
monastery to be quite open and honest to
you a clear no a clear no now when did
it what is the sort of the tougher job
the one you used to have in commercial
TV or the one you have today and what's
the comparison between the two because
we're talking about here was almost
somebody who actually moves between two
different very different fields first of
all they're really different and so was
the most most important thing in my my
times in private television OS running a
private TV production company was at the
end and these times changed so
tremendously over the last year's it was
such a clean clear focus at the end for
commercial aspects know when I started
my career and private TV business it was
more content driven do so many things
you would never leave in our days that
this could happen and and after all
these years or then it was such a
press-up pressure to get to write
figures and to make under economic
aspects when you were working there
where did you get your spiritual
nourishment from what did you go without
spiritual nourishment my spiritual
knowledge meant for the music or for
other Berlin Philharmonic so I've got in
a long lasting relations to this
Orchestra and tues musicians and in my
TV Korea it was it was really if you
have had an idea hmm if you can
generalize it you have had a chance to
realize it Oh in this time it was it was
possible and we were trusted the
beginning and ever no no concrete rules
how to produce and what you have to
produce it was kind time 4x4 try to
figure out what what could work and what
not and it
and open minded and open mind situation
and I we had the idea to do a program
life at from from an island because we
were convinced it's good to a year and
we did it live from enough I was it was
the island it's all but he was very it
was in in the southern part of Europe
and it was and but it was possible this
what I would like to mention and if you
compare it you can't compared with my
actual professional situation hmm what
you could learn from my early or for my
former career is how to handle in her
two stars and create great big creative
people hmm and how to how to handle this
and how to to come to a certain yeah to
a certain agreement because we need the
best soloists conductors in the world
for this Orchestra for the future and
Delvian competitor in competition with
other orchestras and this is what you
have to do in my position okay I think
we'll leave it there we'll move on to
our quiz or traditional quiz at the end
of the show quick questions relatively
quick answers what's more important for
the BPO entertainment or education
education what sir who do you prefer
Bruckner or Beethoven oakna yeah how
great Elvis or Chuck Berry I know you're
a rock and roll man as well no grace and
chuck berry good job is classical music
a dying art or an art for the future
the best hard for the future from the
past that is your lot with Martin
Hoffman and his two careers so far you
never know he might have a third one I
believe somewhere great guest if you've
enjoyed his company as much as I have
come back next week i buy choose